Hopefully, arrays are starting
to make sense to you.
Let's quickly look at
them in another way.
You can think of an array
kind of like this.
It's a set of boxes where each
has an address called an index.
This paper chain is more similar to
a construct called a linked list.
A linked list is an extension of a list,
but it's definitely not an array.
There are still some things that have
order, but there are no indices.
Instead, a linked list is characterized,
well, by its links.
Each element has some notion of what
the next element is since it's connected
to it, but not necessarily how long
the list is or where it is in the list.
An array is different.
There is nothing in one
element of the array that says
here's your next element.
You know what the next element
is by what the next index is.
My first thought when I heard this
was why would anybody ever want to
use a linked list, an array gives you
more information since you already
know where the next element
falls in the array.
However, as we discussed before,
adding and
removing elements from an array
can be really complicated.
Adding and removing elements from
a linked list turns out to be so
easy by comparison.
You can actually just take
an element out or add one in.
There's only one real quick
consideration here, but
we'll talk about that in a minute.